all right John John uh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally I'm
originally from Salt Lake City Utah a
little neighborhood called Rose Park
and tell me about your family you had
Mom and Dad yeah but my parents were
separated since I was real little so I
guess I grew up in two different
households
oh I see after you guys after your
parents divorced
how would you describe yourself then uh
uh like
I'm trying to think of a word for like
turmoil I guess I'm traumatic but it
wasn't it wasn't all bad though I don't
want it to sound you know
so
and I guess I guess the reason I say
that is because
um like as you can see I'm I'm white
um but like I said I grew up in a
neighborhood called Rose Park uh
Roseburg when I was growing up was a
predominantly Latino neighborhood I
think once we hit like around 2010 the
estimate was it was like 60 or 70
percent so they made up the majority of
the neighborhood um there was a really
large gang presence in the neighborhood
which is usually uncommon uh most white
kids don't have their neighborhood
tattooed on their wrist this is Salt
Lake City this Salt Lake City yeah you
wouldn't think there'd be hardcore gangs
in Salt Lake City absolutely not but at
the same time I mean I know people that
are in prison for murder now or
aggravated assaults or all sorts of [ __ ]
by
I guess it goes on everywhere yeah
definitely and you know the bigger like
the bigger the population the more it's
going to happen I mean Salt Lake City
isn't the smallest place on the planet
it's not like it's some small town but
you know when the 80s hit like when the
gang thing hit in California it just
spread all across the country and we
were one of the places that got hit so
you got involved in that yeah so I
wouldn't consider myself a gang member
but a gang associate because I was
always associated with gang members
um and even you know being around them
has led me to get in trouble before even
where our local police force made me
hold up a little whiteboard with my
nickname and what like what said I was
hanging out with so
yeah and you went through High School
you made it through I didn't I actually
graduated from an alternative high
school but I made it and I have a little
bit of college under my belt too
what kind of trouble did you get into
being an associate
um
we pulled over on suspicion of a
drive-by shooting
um
like stolen property we had gang units
um One time my friend was about to the
person who was on this necklace he's
passed away now but uh he was getting in
a fight with another individual and gang
unit happened to be rolling by as the
fight was happening so they chased us
into the house and
that ended up with my friend getting
arrested a dad getting deported a family
being broken up it was crazy and it was
all within a matter of minutes
how did this childhood that you had
affect you now that you're an adult
um
I wish it didn't but uh in reality it
led to like the trauma led to and it's
not just this but other things from my
past it led to a lot of drug use I have
been
um and on again off again everyone user
since 2013 and in the past year or the
past probably
six months it escalated to Fentanyl
so you know once you quit getting high
from heroin you switch over to the next
best thing so that's still something you
deal with yeah
um but my whole reason for coming to
California was to get myself clean
um the only clean time that I ever had
um I basically ended up homeless in
Denver Colorado and was forced to like
get myself back on my feet if I wanted
to survive and I was able to get it down
for a little bit but I relapsed because
I got really really depressed and I
didn't understand what was going on
later I would end up finding out that I
was actually I was bipolar and that was
my reason for relapsing and part of the
reason I've struggled so bad with
substance abuse and being on and off
homeless at different times in my life
and that combination makes it rough yeah
it does drug addicted bipolar homeless
yeah and I mean yeah if you like just
like you say you put all three together
and that's just a ticking Time Bomb so
at this point I'm just
I want to get clean
um I was literally living in my mom's
basement just using drugs she was just
frustrated every day she like literally
didn't know what to do with me she
didn't want to throw me out on the
streets because she knows what goes on
out there and she knows that I've been
out there before
um but at the same time you know she
doesn't want me living under her roof
using drugs in the house and you know
just
being nobody I guess it's hard for a
parent it is it is definitely and I've
you know that's like one thing I think
all drug users take for granted is how
hard it is on their parents on why their
parents might kick them out or why they
may not you know it's your parents don't
kick you out because they don't love you
they're doing it because they love you
you know they're separating themselves
from you because they love you so much
they can't bear to watch you
self-destruct
yeah it's it's it's a really complicated
situation it is because enabling kicks
in faster than you can
yeah recognize it and like I said my mom
like you know she was just trying to do
the right thing she didn't want me to be
out in the streets you know in Utah gets
really cold in the winters homeless
people die every winter because of you
know the snow and how freezing it gets
like it's you know it's not something
that's easy to deal with so you know and
like I said she was just stuck in
between am I gonna let him continue to
use under my roof or am I going to kick
him out and let this be the final straw
and so this time I decided to make the
decision and say
I'll figure it out for myself Aldi I'm
29 29. so you're gonna stay out here and
you're going to try to yes get clean so
yeah the whole point is I you know
because as I've been around today it's
not I've been to La before I have family
out here so that's part of the reason I
chose out here is because I have
somebody out here that you know is kind
of scouting and trying to you know
trying to help me along with my getting
clean but you know like you can you can
look at skid row and there's you know
many many a tent filled with people
right now that are you know just in a in
a very vicious cycle
um but I came out here because it's not
like there aren't programs in Utah it's
just the programs in Utah are very very
miniscule compared to like what is out
here and the money that is invested out
here like they are really trying to get
people off the streets out here but it's
only if you want the help so I decided
I'm going to take the help
what's been the roughest part of your
your journey here
um
honestly just
knowing that I'm back on my own but I'm
on my own in a different sense I'm not
just relying on myself I'm on my own
starting from
below bottom I'm you know I'm starting
out from the streets and we'll just
basically be working myself up
so you know I brought some methadone I
basically was taking my methadone from
the clinic and spitting it out so I
could save it up save it literally so I
snuck it on the plane so I could just
make sure that while I was here I could
use it to taper so that way I'm not
throwing up in the streets and just you
know wasting like you know even
literally just I would end up going back
into it so
I'm just trying to you know trying to
put myself back together
do you have a program to go to yet no so
I've looked at a couple things I think
first and foremost is going to be
housing whether that be temporary
permanent and then I want to get into a
program but I think that that should be
first and foremost because I don't think
I'll be able to focus too much if I'm
running around on Skid Row or running
around downtown so it's easy to get
stuck down yeah it is 100 and it's just
you you see it like you look outside the
door and it is there it is there drugs
are there if you want them and one thing
I've learned is I've lived in this is
the sixth State I've lived in I mean
I've tried to outrun this a lot and
everywhere I've been drugs are
everywhere like it literally doesn't
matter what you're looking for you will
find it in small towns in Montana with
700 people the smaller town the more
it's the more out of control it is dude
you'll find an eight ball of cocaine in
a town of 700 people where you don't
think it could make it from Mexico and
it made it right there yeah it's an
entire country yeah and so it you know
you have to really like it's one of
those things you have to want it and I'm
just point in my life where I've
man like I don't know how to like
describe it but now more than ever it's
like it's like a hunger I guess if you
want to put it that way because I don't
you know I don't want to I don't want to
be 40 years old telling War Stories I
don't want to you know I don't want to
heed somebody not to go down the path
that I've gone down I feel like we
should just have enough people mess up
and then we should just realize that
that's not not a well not a way to go
man you know like opiates you know we we
learned with the opiate crisis like we
learned that you can't over prescribe
opiates you can't give 15 year olds
painkillers for you know getting a tooth
pulled you can't do stuff like that
because it leads to a hectic situation
that there's no easy way to solve
and yeah I was one of those people that
got those prescriptions way early so we
were abusing painkillers in high school
so it was nothing new when I finally
tried heroin I tried heroin at 17. I
didn't actually get addicted until 19
because I had only tried it a couple
times it wasn't until I buckled down and
for whatever reason decided this is the
drug I'm gonna use but
what do you think got you into this
cycle of addiction uh I'm gonna say
he this raving because what raving does
is you take drugs like ecstasy LSD party
drugs and what it does is it makes drugs
seem like they're harmless it gives you
a false sense because you're like wait I
took that and you're like I might have
felt a little bad the next day but
you're like nothing super harmful came
from it so it gives you this misleading
idea that you can try other drugs
without consequence and the thing is you
know drugs like cocaine heroin
methamphetamine those drugs have
consequences
even though it may be Slimmer with
something like MDMA I wouldn't say
there's no consequence to it because it
all seems to lead to the same path if
that makes sense and I've heard other
people come on here and say the same
thing where they started raving they
were doing mushrooms they did this and
then it turned into a full-blown drug
addiction because they kind of like they
I'm trying to think about what they they
okayed it in their head it seemed okay
at the time I guess did you start with
pot yeah definitely I started really
young too like like 11. so you could
almost say the same thing about pot oh
100 I think like it opens the door yes I
think no I think marijuana is a gateway
drug I think people think marijuana is a
lot more benign than it is I think all
drugs really have a negative impact and
can have a seriously negative impact on
your life because one thing is I'm not
going to sit here and lie and say I
don't smoke marijuana every day I do but
does it inhibit me from certain things
yeah it slows me down and it does hold
me back it doesn't hold me back nearly
as much as other drugs but yeah it you
know I wouldn't I wouldn't suggest using
drugs if you want to have
like a decent life I think that's the
best way to put it you know I've never
smoked pot so I don't even know but the
one thing I see from everyone I
interview and and know just in general
outside of this project is
a lot of people don't like dealing with
rough emotions they don't like dealing
with the anger the anxiety the
depression and the pot seems to help
yeah it seems to part of a maturing as
an adult as a human
is dealing with those emotions so they
don't affect you so strongly anymore you
can't just escape with pot every time
you get these emotions because you'll
never mature super smart like Mark you
just point in something out and that's I
mean that's realistically we've heard of
things like that where they say that um
you know using marijuana keeps your
brain at like what like that of like
someone who's in elementary school or in
Middle School I've heard things like
that where your emotional maturity is
like younger than someone it should be
but that's true because if you're not
learning the coping skills on how to
deal with these problems and I will say
that first and foremost I'm somebody who
suffers from mental illness and I never
learned those coping skills my coping
skills were from watching people beat
the [ __ ] out of people or watch people
try to murder other people or watch
people use drugs while people are trying
to hurt other people and you know it
I I mean just to be honest it's not even
an escape because
the drug ends much sooner than you think
it does and reality comes right back
right back in and your circumstances
usually get harder as you they
exacerbate the escaping yeah yeah 100
problems yeah and like and like I said
do I like I'm even saying that even now
when I use marijuana and I still think
it's harmful to me and I still think
it's holding me back and I'm literally
looking at you today saying I'm not
ready to quit it though but I'm ready to
quit fentanyl but I'm not ready to quit
marijuana like you hear that it
it almost sounds like why like you know
it almost sounds pointless it's like why
not just
you know why not just throw it all away
and say hey like you know it's time to
time to start a new but I think that
once I get into a program maybe they'll
help you know help get me on the right
tracker maybe on a better better train
of thought because that's actually you
know that's one thing that my mom
pointed out a lot is that she's like
your thinking isn't right and the
reality is yeah if I've been using drugs
pretty much my whole life like
yeah my thinking isn't right and I'm not
able to correctly deal with emotions and
the thing is is it does perpetuate this
cycle of me becoming homeless me using
more drugs me lashing out at people it
just it does it perpetuates the cycle it
makes it much worse I mean understand
that I just hopped on a plane hopped off
the plane and said I have nowhere to go
have a little bit of money
I really don't have anything and you
probably contacted me and said yeah I do
an interview exactly so I contacted you
um I've looked at a couple of the
homeless shelters and you know we're
basically going to see what happens
because I know how homeless shelters
work it's first some first come first
serve so I'll be basically you know go
and see if I can find a place to what
age did you start using drugs or
whatever okay so marijuana at like 11
but my actual like drug use passed that
really started to kick in in high school
like early High School I started trying
them more benign drugs
but then as we got into 14 15. yeah once
we got into like sophomore year I was
already just ready to take whatever yeah
and then it's a common story yeah by the
time I was 17. just started so early
using hard drugs so by the time I mean
because I use cocaine at 15. so never
mind 15. yeah 15 will just win even my
mom looked at me and said like you know
I've opened Pandora's Box it was the
best way for her to describe it because
she found out my involvement with gangs
she found out like my drug use was like
she thought it was marijuana which a lot
of people think is you know pretty
harmless but then she found out oh it's
past that but you know you got to keep
that Under Wraps she doesn't you know
she doesn't understand that I'm getting
Oxycontin from a girl who's stealing it
from her from her dad who has cancer
and he has now passed away and I mean I
don't know where she is today but I just
know that's the story
what's your biggest regret so far
drugs man like hands down because the
thing is I can't control I couldn't
control moving to Rose Park when I was
younger I couldn't control the friends
that I met because literally I was kind
of a nobody when I grow up I was not
somebody people want to be friends with
so I had to pick it like I had to take
what I could get but if there's one
thing that wasn't my control it was my
use of illicit substances or it doesn't
matter if they were legal or less it
doesn't matter just drug use in general
because that's been my biggest downfall
you say that's the most important thing
you've learned 100 because it's like
Kryptonite to me it may not be like that
for everybody else but looking down here
it seems like it's like that for a lot
of people so and you know now that
around the country it's not just here
but we've seen you know a lot of places
basically lessen the you know the crime
for possessing drugs and less than other
criminal offenses you kind of see people
take advantage like you see people like
oh I don't go to jail anymore so I can
steal from whatever store I want like oh
I don't go to jail for having drugs
anymore I can have more drugs now like
you just see that and it I mean we we
thought it was going to do one thing and
it did the opposite you know like we did
these lenient policies to help people
and it turns out they
might have done the complete opposite
all right John thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you and I wish
you all the luck in the world very much
out here thank you man